attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
elle arrive non mais je te jure je les
retrouvais sur facebook elle était
gaulle et au collège en puis je me dis
peut-être que que quinze ans après il
faut enfin se passer quelque chose quoi
attentionné champagne ça lui est pas
juste a morflé de pris 15 kilos non 21
et pourquoi tes photos facebook y accole
pas être la réalité dans les normales je
n'ai pas choisi depuis cinq ans c'est
pas bien de faire ça bon bah tu es venu
prendre quand même c'est gentil merci
[Musique]
voilà voilà
et je sais pas si tu savais mais j'étais
amoureux tout au collège et au régime
dire parce que le nombre de mecs qui
m'ont peloter aux toilettes au pc je
veut dire un de plus un de moi je
reporte à merde et comment ça se fait
que les prix autant de boire je retrouve
depuis huit ans m'en fous je peux besoin
de sévir il faut que je me suis laissé
les complets coiffure à l'époque avec
tout ce qui était un appareil dentaire
je vais au gras bouton je regarde loin
de quoi ouais c'est une période
compliquée en plus on souhaitait tout le
temps de ma gueule on m'appelait gollum
et ou bien c'était dur était un brevet
pèse c'est moi qui avais lancé surnom ça
avait tellement pris du coup tu m'a
appelé parce que comme tu avais un vieux
souvenir de moi mais en bonne quoi
exactement
je me suis fait larguer ya pas longtemps
et j'ai passé en revue toutes les filles
que j'ai connu et ne m'a rappelé mes
mots ou en ce moment le nombre de mecs
comme toi du comme toi on galère qui me
rappelle après le gars je parle je suis
très heureuse est venu voir comment je
peux détailler mon bonheur jean tap-tap
demers n'a jean couple est seul
[Musique]